on the streets outside the US Embassy in
London another huge turnout for the
second day thousands of protesters out
enforce their passion and calls to
tackle injustice undimmed after the
shocking death of George Floyd in
Minneapolis 14 police officers were
injured in the violence outside dining
Street on Saturday including a mounted
officer thrown from her horse as it
collided with a traffic light
I'm absolutely sickened and appalled by
the level of violence that was on
display police officers were abused and
police officers were injured and we have
a police officer that is seriously
injured and in hospital right now and
that is absolutely unacceptable the
protests in the capital have been
replicated albeit on a smaller scale in
several other UK cities in Bristol
crowds toppled this statue of Edward
Colston
[Applause]
a 17th century trader and MP who
protesters say enriched himself on the
back of the slave trade these latest
protests are another clear rejection of
the government's plea to stay at home
the health secretary again outlining the
risks of marching on mass in the middle
of the coronavirus health emergency it's
undoubtedly risks so you know I support
very strongly the argument that is being
made by those who are protesting for
more equality and against discrimination
but the virus itself doesn't
discriminate and gathering in large
groups is temporarily against the rules
precisely because it increases the risk
of the spread of this virus so I would
urge people to make their argument and I
will I will support you in making that
argument but please don't spread the
this virus which has already done so
much damage as protesters again
congregated in Parliament Square and the
area around Whitehall police
reinforcements were close by inside
streets hoping they won't be needed but
ready in the event of trouble
mark White's Tiny's
[Applause]